What's the negative of buying supplements through Amazon?
When we do sell some of our supplements through Amazon,
the problem with buying supplements through Amazon in general
is that you don't know for sure if you're getting the real thing.
So you don't really realize how possible it is
for a Chinese company, which I say a Chinese company
because 99% of the time it is a Chinese company that is doing this.
Literally buy, let's say, pick a designs for health product
or an ortho molecular product or a PHP product.
They buy it, the bottle of it from the company,
and then they literally scan and reproduce the label.
And they fill capsules with literally just rice brand.
And they sell it as the product.
That's why most of the companies that we sell on our website,
on our store do not let us sell on Amazon.
They don't let us sell it on Amazon because otherwise,
it's too hard to chase down all these Amazon companies.
So there's so many companies that are selling bad supplements already.
Legally, not just these fake companies that are selling fake designs
for health products on Amazon.
But there's companies that are selling,
you could go to Walmart or Target and you could buy a bottle of ashwaganda,
and you could bring it to your local biochemistry lab.
And if you know the biochemist and you could ask him to test the,
is there actually 200 milligrams of ashwaganda in each capsule?
They'll find in most of the products
that you can even get at GNC, Target, Walmart, whatever.
They'll find that it contains less than 10%
what it says on the label.
So it's just, well, it's so much cheaper to buy it at Costco.
Can't I just buy this product at Costco?
I'm not saying that there's not maybe a good tumor product at Costco.
But you're taking your chances, most of the stuff that you're getting
is not good stuff.
A lot of the little supplement companies and things have been bought out
by the drug companies too,
and they're not selling good stuff.
Why? Because they can.
Because they could get away with it.
Because nobody's getting it tested.
They're not getting independent testing done.
So you have to buy reputable stuff
or you're just not getting the real stuff.
That's just, there's been studies I've referenced them
in the past multiple times.
Independent studies that have literally got it
and bought products at different stores
and on Amazon and test it.
And they just don't, some of them had nothing in it.
There was just rice bread.
And some of them had some ashwagonder,
some whatever, herb liver, testine or supplement.
Did have the dosage that was in that,
what I was in the capsule,
I was listed on the label.
So you take your chance.